One thing I want all of you to do is start looking and
understanding image formats a little bit.
Look at how the color channels are distributed.
And also what information we can extract about image compression.
And also these days, of course, most camera formats have a EXIF, or
Exchangeable Image File Format.
Which has information including of course, the width and
the height of the image.
But also things like how it is coded and
what are the compressions associated with it.
But more importantly these things also has information like the date the image
was captured geotags, and other information that's added in
as an additional data structure with an image data cell.